Oh,
Rogers was a phenomenologist.
It's useful to know what that means
because you hear people use words all
the time,
like why?
Maybe not all the time,
probably not usually like phenomenology
or existentialism,
postmodernism and structuralism and all
those things.
It's not.
It's frequently the case that
it isn't that easy to figure out what
the dark cloud.
That's because they don't know.
No,
because it's actually quite difficult to
make a reasonable conceptual distinction
between all those different modes of
thinking and phenomenology came out of
philosophy and its earliest advocate was
a guy named Edmund and its most famous
proponent was probably heidegger,
heidegger garden,
lots of trouble because he ended up
supporting the Nazis at least to some
degree,
so that's pretty good reason to get in
trouble.
All things considered,
you know,
although you know most people in
Germany,
so not that's any excuse obviously.
It's hard to exactly get your head
around what the phenomenologists are
talking about.
I was reading about David chalmers this
morning.
I don't know how many of you know about
David Chalmers,
but he's a philosopher who started the
Tucson conventions on consciousness and
chalmers.
I'm not sure what I think about
gentleman.
He's very charismatic.
He's got a way with words and setting up
those convention center has done a great
deal for the study of consciousness.
But um,
sometimes I think that what he pointed
out to scientists was obvious.
It was funny,
you know,
when they're,
when psychology was primarily
behaviorist,
which was back in the fifties,
it came as a big shock to psychologists
when certain psychologist started to
talk about cognition.
They called that the cognitive
revolution and you know,
I think it was obvious to everybody,
but psychologists at that point that
people fought and I think it was perhaps
the same situation with philosophers and
it's pretty obvious to everybody that
consciousness was a tough nut to crack.
But the philosophers kind of ignored it
and chalmers brought it back into the
academic mainstream.
The phenomenologists are really all
about consciousness.
They just accepted as a fact.
I'm rather than trying to deny its
existence because it can't be easily
reduced to its material.
Substrate.
Chalmers big point was that he couldn't
understand why evolution couldn't have
produced creatures exactly like us who
have no conscious awareness that you
called them,
fundamentally said that the existence of
consciousness is an enduring mystery.
Well,
I think that's true.
I don't.
I'm not sure that we've got anywhere in
terms of figuring out exactly what
consciousness is,
despite a lot of time and effort put
into it and despite a lot of tremendous
amount of work done on the brain,
but anyways,
the phenomenologists are.
They just took it as a fact.
Now,
heidegger believe that western
philosophy had lost its way really since
the time of the Greeks,
and he thought that phenomenology or the
philosophies,
primary field of focus should be being
itself,
not reality,
but being.
And it's not easy to understand what he
meant by being,
but
the phenomenal field.
The idea of a phenomenal field somewhat
captures it.
So
for Heidegger,
reality was what you experienced.
So he sort of,
you sort of tip the tables instead of
presuming an objective world and then
deriving the subjective from it.
He presumed that
the entirety of your experiences were
real
and that included your emotions and your
felt motivational states and your dreams
and your fantasies and even your
delusions.
Now,
that doesn't mean that people like
heidegger thought that all the elements
of lived reality belonged in the same
category,
so if you thought that
dreams and the reality that you've
shared with other people were
indistinguishable from one another,
you'd be just as pathological to a
phenomenologist as to anyone else,
but they were trying to get back to the
central mystery of life,
which is that
there is something rather than nothing.
I suppose the neck.
We experienced it
and that's the place where Roger Starts.
One of the presumptions of,
of the Rogerian is,
is that in order to help someone,
you have to put yourself in their shoes
fundamentally.
So you have to try to see the world from
their perspective,
and that means adopting
the viewpoint.
It means adopting the reality that
manifests itself to them
so that you can develop an empathic
understanding,
body focused understanding of the person
that you're talking to you.